[Music]
okay I am so excited the deliciously
villainous ghost Hannah John Comyn is in
studio today thank you so much for
joining us thank you for having me you
have had so your first acting roles 2011
but I want to talk about like the
whirlwind of geek fandom that you've
been a part of because we've got Game of
Thrones Star Wars Tomb Raider ready
player one and now Marvel skipping
through different universes world just
you know just having just trying it all
out ya know it's been it's been nuts
it's been amazing and to joins the
Marvel Universe it's I mean it I'm
honored
what were you into growing up well
growing up I I mean I loved you know my
Barbies I loved I really loved my super
Superman comics and my Batman comics I
am obsessed with the Joker I had all of
the like Arkham Asylum and the mad love
and everything between you know
Harlequin and the Joker so I I did like
my comic books yeah from my toys that's
awesome so when you get this role of
ghost who is a character in the comics
but there's not like a ton to go off of
so was that kind of freeing for you or
did you feel like it was more of a
challenge to actually adapt this
character it was completely 100% free I
was actually really glad that there was
no big ghost origin story in any comics
you know because obviously ghost is you
know written as a male character and all
I know is that you know ghost was with
the Thunderbolt team and also with Iron
Man and I remember I got the comics and
I was reading but it's like okay ghosts
they're then kind of goes disappears and
no not there anymore okay great that's a
really freeing thing because I can
really take him off off the page and
give her life you know and it was it was
great it was we can really start from
scratch and and really bring ghosts
alive right and you don't have anybody
being like well they better get a B C
and D I exactly there's no expectation
from the comic book it's it's great it's
like nope we can really completely go
with it yeah yeah you know approaching
the character ghost is you know I didn't
I didn't look her as a villain I didn't
think in my mind she's a villain she's
gonna be bad it's like no she's badass
but I approached it that yes she is the
threat
in the movie she's the threat to the
heroes in the movie she is the
antagonist but you know there's no such
thing as a villain being a villain you
know there's there's a reason and
actually in her mind she's misunderstood
and everybody else for the bad guys and
she's the good guy so I definitely
wanted to make sure that that you know I
had that and translate it there there
was like I feel like for a couple of the
previous Marvel movies there's been some
really great like compelling villains
whereas maybe before you know was a
criticism where was kind of a monster of
the week kind of thing but she is like a
very complex person so I mean just to
add on to that what do you think it is
about her that makes her so compelling
as an antagonist I think she's I mean
she's very mysterious she's got a lot of
depth and I think the audience they're
gonna feel very kind of confused with
her motives I mean she has got very
clear objective in the movie but I think
the audience are gonna kind of go hmm
push and pull between the heroes and and
ghosts also I mean the fact that she can
phase through things yeah I mean her
powers are pretty special we haven't
seen that so that's that's gonna be
really cool
I loved the suit by the way I like I
thought you looked so awesome in it I
was wondering you know when you're
actually doing the fight scenes this
don't work
I read you did a lot of your own yeah
how did the suit kind of lend itself to
the physicality of the character those
suits were hearts they were really warm
it was kind of a three-man job
after they call cut like G fans cooling
before every weirdo and I used to
actually request em I did my stunts
rehearsals in my costume because I
wanted to see what we could really do
and if there was anything injuring me or
actually if we were surprised I'm going
oh no no put that boot back in because I
can do it the suits great that was
awesome I definitely with the mask the
eyes don't line up they kind of go like
there so I I had they had to take out
parts of the mask for fights no just for
safety because I couldn't see right
Hanabi you know punching anyone in the
nose but no it was it was it was really
fun actually it's a kind of it makes you
feel different when you have your suit
on you just go oh
it makes your character it makes me you
just feel strong and it gives it that
swag like ghost swag right bound well
I'd like a lot of people you know in the
Marvel movies they always have that
moment where they're like oh this is the
moment I realized I was actually a part
of the Marvel Universe did you have that
moment on set yeah I did I did it was
kind of when you get suited and booted
and you're standing there on a Marvel
set and you see everybody else and
you're going okay I'm here this is
actually happening I mean it's a pinch
pinch yourself moment I always have it
and I don't think it's quite sunken in
yet
I don't think I ever will there's a
moment you know ghosts and wasp kind of
fight it out and I am like I got like
weirdly emotional just seeing like two
badass women going head to head and you
know I'm looking at maybe it's directed
by man it's written by men but it feels
like it really understood women in this
movie and how they they're the ones that
get it done was that did you guys have
any conversations like you and
Evangeline and Peyton about the handling
of your characters because I felt like
there was it was so well understood it
was well it was a hundred percent 100
percent well and I said I I adore this
is why I do a painting for this because
he really really gave myself and
Evangeline actually like a platform in a
forum as well to be to be able to
understand each other because with the
characters of ghosts and and hope and
there's so many similarities there's so
many differences but there's any
similarities and and you know I think
that the progression of having more
strong female characters you know
whether it's a villainous or hero I
think characters that are strong and and
tough and hold their own in the Marvel
Universe is definitely needed more you
know hmm and it didn't it felt so real
and like unforced - we're not like oh
they're just like shoehorning this
strong female character in there that's
like no these women just exist in this
universe and they are strong yeah
females exactly and there's a moment you
know where like I'm not gonna give
anything away but you know guys are
going at it and and hopes just like guys
we focus for a minute and it's like it's
just such a parallel so like the real
world
good I would say like palate cleanser
from infinity war and all the
destruction that we've felt and
heartbreak it is like a smaller scale
movie pun intended but how do you feel
like it does acknowledge the larger
universe around it during the movie if
there's anything you could tease about
that I think well I think definitely I
think after infinity war you you kind of
need you need to want that man but with
the Marvel characters I mean it's
amazing because you there's so many
different worlds in the Marvel Universe
and so many different stories and
characters and how they intertwine and
interlink and you know you just never
know what's gonna happen next
[Laughter]
[Music]